hello everyone i am ang and welcome to
simply learn today we will take you
through the hands-on lab demo of how you
can create a text to speech converter
application using python
before we start i hope the screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them
let's wait for some more minutes to let
other people join
i'm repeating again before we start i
hope the screen is clearly visible and
the audio is fine if yes please type in
yes if there are any issues do let us
know in the chat section so that we can
resolve them
until then let me tell you guys that we
have regular updates on multiple
technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and press that bell icon to
never miss any updates from simply learn
i'm repeating again let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hand for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting to subscribe to our youtube
channel and press that bell icon to
never miss any update from simply learn
it i think we can get started in today's
session we will go through what is text
to speech converter after that we will
create text to speech converter
application using python
this
we will create this one
we will perform different functions and
create amazing ui for application using
different python libraries before we
move on to the programming part let's
discuss what is text to speech converter
and proceed further for the same
text to speech is an api cloud service
that enables you to turn return text
into real sounding audio in a range of
languages and voices
by connecting with people in their own
language you can give your business a
voice and enhance customer experience
and engagement
increasingly accessibility of users of
diverse abilities offering audio
alternatives to prevent driving while
distracted or automating customer
service interaction to reduce hold items
let's move to our programming part to
create a text to speech converter
application using python
so first we will open command prompt to
write command to open jupyter notebook
so here we will write jupyter
notebook
to open jupyter notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page or jupyter
notebook and select open new python file
so this is how the jupyter ui looks like
so at first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
in creating ui and to convert text to
speech
so the first one is
import
sorry
import
ek enter
as
tk
so tk enter is also known as tk
interface the default python interface
for tcl tk gui toolkit is the tk enter
package or ticker interface
majority of unix system including mac os
as well as windows machine support tk
and tk intern
tkinter which is part of all common
python distribution is the binding legal
method for creating graphical user
interface gui in python
it is the only framework included in the
python standard library in fact
so the next one is
first we will write here
import
sorry
from
tk enter
put
from
tk enter
port
file
file dialog tk enter provides a number
of built-in methods and class library
function to create application
components and user actionable elements
one of the tk enter modules called file
dialog offers classes and library
functions for making windows for
selecting files and dictionaries
when you need to request that a user
browser file or directory on the system
you can use file dialog
so
the next one is
import
combo box
combo box combines an entry field and a
list box
one of the tk enter visits
it has down arrow to choose from a menu
of possibilities it dates consumer in
choosing from the list of available
options
a pop-up of scrolling list box is
displayed down the entry field when user
clicks on the drop down arrow on the
entry field
only when option from the list box is
selected will the select option be shown
in the enter field
this one is
it is one of the major one import
ey
e t x
s x three
okay
so a python text to speech conversion
library is called p y t t s x three it
is compatible with python 2 and 3 and
works offline unlike computing libraries
to obtain a reference to our pyttx
library
engine instance an application called
the
x3 init
factory method it is a very user
friendly program that turns type text to
speech
this api file for windows program offers
two voices that the pytas x3 module
supports a female voice and a male voice
3tts engines are supported by it
windows sappy i5
nss speech for mac os
e-speak is available on all other
platform
so
the next one is
import
os
so the os module in python has function
for adding and deleting folders
retrieving their contents changing the
directory locating the current directory
and more before you can communicate with
the underlying operating system you must
import the os module
the next one is
from
gtts
import
dts
from
play sound
import
a sound
so gtts
python has a variety of apis that can
turn text into speech the google text to
speech api often known as gtts api
is one of these apis gtts is a simple to
use program that turns enter text into
audio that can be saved as mp3 file
languages including english hindi tamil
french german spanish and many more are
supported via gtts api
any one of the two accessible audio
speeds rapid or slow may be used to
deliver the speech
the voice of created audio however
cannot be changed as the most recent
version
so let me run this
so after importing major libraries let's
move forward and start creating user
interface
so i will write here
import
sorry
root
equals to
tk
put
dot
title
simply learn
to
speech converter
root dot
geometry
i will give a thousand
580
plus
200 from y-axis and
and
80 from top
okay
root dot resizable
will make into like false
false
and again false
okay
then
dot
configure
background should be pg equals to
use here hash
f7
ac
four zero
and
okay first i will explain this so here
tk stands for tk inter library
every word in the string returned by the
title
method begins with an uppercase letter
like a title or a header the following
letter will be changed to uppercase if
the word contains a number or a symbol
one of the built-in methods in tk enter
is geometry
which is used to specify dimension while
tk inter widget windows are mostly used
to set the application windows dimension
length
the tk enter root windows size can be
changed in accordance with the needs of
the user using the resizable
this one
or we can forbid resizing of the tk
enter window in other words this
approach can be used to generate a
window with a defined size
simple text changes can be made to
labels using python tk interconfig
function
two widgets are shown in the example
below
a label and a button when the button is
pressed a function that is attached to
the button execute the label config
method
you can give background color as per
your choice i gave
this
orange something
so
let's run this and see the first look of
ui by writing
here i will write here
root
dot
main loop
i will run and all
okay
so this is how our ui looks like first
ui
so i can't resize because i gave here
false false
i can't resize it
so if
i will write here
set of false i will write here true
and again
prove here
so then i will run again
[Music]
so now i can resize it as per my choice
okay
yeah
so i will write here
false
and again false
meant it
okay let's move forward and add some
logos in the application
i have already some png images on my
system you guys can use any picture of
your choice
i have some images here
images
so
you guys can use any picture of your
choice
so i will write here
simply
underscore logo
first two photo
image
file
then path of file
slp
09375
top
then
ets folder
yes
folder then
simply
dot png
then i will set label
put
h
equals to
employee image
simply logo sorry
and background
i can copy from here
dot
place
equals to
880
and y-axis should be
like i will give here
5
30.
okay
let's run this
root
dot in loop
here there is something error
such file directory
okay there is fun
now let me run this
yeah
now you can see simply learn is there i
need
a little bit down
so let me write again
give here
39
run it again
okay now it's looking good
yeah
the image object is returned by the
photo image function
output it's that easy to display a
picture in python however the photo
image class only supports the gif and
png images
which is a concern
jpeg and gpg and png are the formats
that are most often used
the container box where the text or
images can be placed is specified by the
label
the widget is used to inform the user or
other widgets that are utilized in the
python application
the text or a portion of the text shown
in the label can be configured using a
number of different parameters
the root window
is where all the widgets are placed
this one the root window is this all the
widgets are placed
even tk enter application must include
precisely one increase of the class dk
which is an instance of app is a
subclass of frame
and app is in instance of app
by positioning them in a precise
location with the parent widget the port
manager organize widgets the option used
by the geometry manager are anchor
border mode height width
real width
x and y anchor
shows the location where the widget is
anchored
okay let's move forward and add logo
here
instead of this add one logo here
so i will make it comment down
run it
so for that i will write logo underscore
image
equals to
photo
image
and file
let's do
we'll copy the path from here
sit here
okay
so let me change it to speech
dot png
perfect
so root
dot
icon photo
false
for my logo
underscore image
put dot
main
let me run this
yeah now you can see a logo here
so
the image object is returned by the
photo image function
output it is the easy to display a
picture in python however the photo
image class only supports the gif and
pgm which is a concern jpeg gpg and png
are the formats that are most often used
the title bar icon of the tk enter top
level window is set using the icon photo
but in order to set any image as a title
bar icon it must be an object of the
photo image class
so okay logo is added
this logo is added
now we will make one upper frame like
this one upper frame
till here something like here
and we will add the heading and logo in
the frame
okay
so let me
do this let me make it as a command
so i will write here
upper frame
first to frame
root
and background should be
you can use any color
i will write here hashtag 1 4
a
7 dd
cool
then width should be
1500
yes i can give you 1200 is enough
and height should be
1
30 is fine
upper
m dot place
is equals to
zero
and
y equals to your x and y equals to zero
y because we need at the top
so i will add one
picture there so picture
pursue
again photo
image
i can copy from
yeah
same image i will add
and label
and when i'm where i'm
adding here is like upper
frame
image equals to
here background
should be the same
and dot place
goes to
150
and y should be
like i will give you 20.
okay
so let me run this
root
dot main
two
we'll run this run all
okay
okay there i have to write
y equals to 20
and again
okay here
what they should f is capital
hope now it will run properly
so the image is added here
yeah for the purpose of grouping and
arranging other widgets in a user
friendly manner the frame widget is
crucial
it functions like a container that
organizes the positioning of other
widgets
to arrange the layout and provide these
widgets the screen uses rectangular
regions
the root window is where all the widgets
are placed even tk enter application
must include precisely one instance of
the class tk
and the label is specifies the container
box where the text images can be placed
these widgets used to inform the user or
the other widgets that are utilized in
the python application
the text or a portion of the text shown
in the label can be configured using
several different parameters
okay so logo is added and it's looking
great
so
i hope you guys understand till here if
you have any question or any query
regarding
any sort of code
so just put as in comment our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
i'm repeating again i hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
questions or any query regarding any
code
or if there are any questions related to
python just put as in comments our team
will shortly provide you the correct
solution moving forward let's add a
heading to the application
so i will make it as a comment
first i will add
some
[Music]
else below
better view
okay
so for that i will write here label
i have to head heading at the upper
frame so i will write here upper frame
should be
will give
x
to
each
converter
on should be
new
woman
okay side should be 40 is enough i guess
and it should be bold
background color should be
i will add this one only
so
copy
paste it here
and foreground should be
white
and dot place
at x
equals to 250
and y should be the same i guess i
should be
i will write 35
to 30.
let's run this root
dot main loop
run this
okay it's like option front
okay this is font i
want sorry my bad
oh it will work
i guess
yeah
so here you can see
x is added
so for the purpose of grouping and
arranging other widgets in user friendly
manner the frame widget is crucial it
functions like a container that
organized positioning of the other
widgets
and the labels specify the container box
where the text or images can be placed
this widget is used to inform the user
of other widgets that are utilized in
the python application
and in tk enter there are three
different ways to specify a widget type
to put it simply use the string format
tk
direct font format
times 20 italic or bold
upon family size styles is the structure
of the string
where style can be any legal mashup of
text style keywords
okay so heading is added now let's move
forward and make our text box for
writing text to it
so let me make first
as a comment
okay
so we are creating text box so i will
write here text box
equals
to text
and root window so i will write here
root
font
so let me tell you first i will create a
text box like this
or this
so font
equals to
library
20. and background should be black or
white
okay let's do black first
let it take it white only white
and relief is something
relief equals to
groove
and
wrap
keywords into
word or characters word
word
and border width should be
zero
okay
so text
box
dot place
should i place it x equals to
30
comma y equals to
150
comma width
it
should be i will make it the longer one
so i will write here
940
then
height
should be
180
so let's run this first root dot
main loop
let me run it
so yeah
xbox is created
hello guys
yeah
so text box is created so the python
application uses the text widgets to
display text data the single line text
box is implemented using the entry
widgets which tkinter offers the
multi-line style text is with a variety
of styles and characteristics is shown
using the text widget
instead of group you can use
raised flat bridge and many more
it is used to make contact within a text
document with
using the rav features in tkinter we may
enclose the characters or words in the
tk widgets
you can use word cats or none are the
available default values for the wrap
properties
the tk enter button bd option determines
the width or stroke of the border
that encircles the button
the width of the board around a button
can be changed using the bd
so by positioning them in a precise
location with the parameter
the put manager organized visits the
option used by this geometry manager our
anchor border mode height width
x and y and many more
so our text box is created
you can write anything
now let's move forward and add some
combo box for selecting voice and speed
so first
i will but i will do it i will make it
comment
here i will write
gender box
for male female
so it goes to
combo
box
put
value
if the question
email
and font should be
should be
your font should be r
o b o
c e
and 12 shells would be 12
then there is something called state
and then
width
12
and
gender box
what place
so i will place something here
something here like gender should be
here and speed should be here
so i will write here
equals to
40
comma
y equals to
400
and gender box
or set
to mail
run it so root dot main
let me run this
yeah so you can see male female
yeah
just combo box
so a combo box combines an entry field
and a list box
one of the tinker widgets it has down
arrow to choose from a menu of
possibilities it aids consumers in
choosing from the list of available
option
a pop-up of scrolling list box is
displayed down the entry field when the
user clicks on the drop down arrow on
the entry field
only when an option from the list box is
selected with the selected option be
shown in the entry field
if i will select errors then it will
show female
male
so some variables supported by tk enter
can be used to change the values of tk
inter widgets
each variable operates as a typical
variable would
the values of these variable are set and
retrieved using the set and get methods
combobox combines a listbox widget and
an entry widget
you can choose one value from a group of
values using a combobox widget
you can also input a custom value in
addition
so settext is used to set the text in
the entry box
in the python tk enter
it serves the purpose of entering text
into the entry box when used as a
function
we will write a function and use as a
button to invoke it
so okay so it's look great
moving forward let's add one more combo
box for the speed one
like fast medium and slow
so whatever i will do
i will copy
first i will make it as a comment
so
first i will copy this and i will paste
it here
and i will write
beatbox
again
beatbox
again
and i will set it to medium
and there will be three values
like fast
pm
and
slow
and i will place combo box
where should i place
will place it
something
like
here i will place it here
so
for that
i have to give x as
around 540
and y should be same
so let me run this
and let's see
so yeah
so it's looking fine function i use here
is same as the previous one that we did
for the gender one for this one
so i hope you guys understand till here
if you have any question or any query
regarding
any code
any sort of code so just put as in
comments our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution i'm repeating
again i hope you guys understand till
here if you have any question or any
query regarding any code just put as in
comments our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution
so moving forward
let's add play button to playing the
return text
but before
that let's add something called select
voice and select speed label for these
two combo box
for like select select voice type and
select speed
so let's add them quickly
so i will write here label
i am adding it to the root window so i
will write here root
and text
equals to
select
voice type
and font
could be
times
common
size should be like 15 is enough i guess
it should be bold
some
background color should be i will
here
copy
paste
yeah
foreground color should be
white
hot place
equals
to
40
and y equals to
the 70
okay let me copy this for the speed
copy it and i will paste it here
i will write here speed
everything is same
cut it and i will paste it here for the
running
let me run this
lactic speed is there i don't know where
you select okay
okay i gave the same x values i guess
yeah
so here i have to write 540
let me run this again
select voice
male female select speed fast medium
flow
so the python application uses the text
widget to display the text data the
single line text box is implemented
using the entry widget which tkinter
offers
the foreground color of a button is set
using the tk enter button fg parameter
alternately the text color is on the
button
so it is looking cool
now moving forward let's add play button
somewhere here
so
i will write code for it
a
button
[Music]
i have one photo for it
photo
let me copy the path
and play
let's go btn
first to
button
text
equal to
x should be
play
there is something called
compound
a button
comma
background should be
[Music]
white
and
width
is 130
pond
goes to
ariel
hold
um
border width
should be
[Music]
point
one
e
c means centimeter
and there is something called
command
equals to
peak now
a
let's go
ptn dot
place
x should be
435
y
should be
450
let me see
root
dot main
two
come make it comment
okay
okay okay
so this is a function
we haven't created function yet so i
will add it at the last
so till
see
this
border width
okay okay w i d t h
i hope now it will work
it's
a python application can add buttons by
using the button widget these button can
show text or images that explain what
they are for when a button is clicked
you can connect a function or method
that is called automatically using that
command
so here compound determined the best way
to display text and an image or the
label cursor
define how the mouse will look when it
over the widget
so the
tk enter button bd option control the
border width or stroke surrounding the
button
and some tk enter widgets let you use
command binding to link a callback
function to an event
it enters that you may specify a
function name in the widgets command
option
so that it will be called whenever an
event occurs on the widget
okay so our ui for the text to speech
converter application is created and it
is looking fabulous
so now let's add function for converting
the text to speech sound
let me write the code first and then i
will explain you line wise
okay
now we can write here
command
equals to
peak now
okay
so what i will do i will add a function
here
i will add function here
so let me write the code first then i
will explain you linewise lies
so
here i will write ets tts is nothing
just text to speech variable
pytt
sx3
dot init
ef for function speak now
next
equals to
x underscore box
dot get
1.0
till the end
gender
equals to
gender box
dot get
and speed
was to speed
the scorebox
dot
get
voices
equals to tts
dot
property
voices
okay so there is one another function
set voice
if
gender
that
property
it should be capital
property
[Music]
yeah
voice
if voice id versus id should be
hero
dot id
ets
dot say
whatever written
on text
i'm done for then
else
pts
dot
that
property
voice
voices
dot id
pts
dot say
text
and again tds dot
done
and
here i will for
i will write code for that speed if
text
and again if
speed
first equals to
fast
and
ets dot set
property
and rate
rate should be
250
or else if
speed
also equals to
m
so then
ets dot set
property
and rate should be
150
that
voice function will be called
else
eds dots that
property
it has dot set property and rate should
be
it should be
60
at
voice
okay so function is created
dot get dot get get property fine text
okay
now let me run this
so let me explain you
ts is nothing just a variable
to text to speech and init pytts x3
engine has started obtains a pointer to
an instance of an engine that will
utilize the specified driver if another
engine instance is already using the
given driver
the other engine instance is returned if
not a new engine is built
so speak now is a function which using
get function i am getting the values of
that text box voice
i will show you it
so
from this
from this speak now i am getting the
value of text
male and female then
speed
and using the get property i am getting
the voices of male and female
in set voice what i did using id 0 for
male and assetting into the male
and using id 1 for female and assigning
it to the female
and in this lc flatter i am setting
speed to a particular values using the
rate function and assigning them speed
in frames per second
so now let's see text to speech
converters is working or not
so what i will write here
hello
coders
welcome
to
simplylearn
oh i will play
hello coders welcome to simple learn
hope you hear the sound
i repeat hope you heard the sound
and same thing i will from
from female
object run and wait
okay there is an error
run and wait
i will write
let me run this again
hello simply learn
lo simply learn
and again with female voice
hello simple learn
i will write here hello simply
learners
subscribe
to our
youtube
channel hello simple learners subscribe
to our youtube channel
and i will play it too fast
hello simple learners subscribe to our
youtube channel
then i will be slow
hello simple learners
subscribe to our youtube channel
[Music]
so
i hope you guys understand till here if
you have any questions or any query
regarding any code just put as in
comments our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution
i hope you guys must have understood how
to create your own text to speech
converter using python
if you have any queries you can ask in
the comment section below our team will
respond you as soon as possible if you
want this full code just comment for the
same thank you so much for being here if
you enjoyed this video please do
subscribe to our youtube channel and
give a like to this video
thank you and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here